my name is ace Valerie yes that is my
real name I had it legally changed in
2007 I'm 32 years old been here in
Portland Oregon since 2003 I am a Jedi
realist I practiced the philosophies
that were first introduced in the Star
Wars right now my fiancee and I are
living in our truck a while back our
rent was raised we both have jobs I make
decent money but it's just too expensive
to live in an apartment these days
Jediism is not about the magic tricks as
part of my faith I intentionally placed
myself in a position where I can help
the most people I didn't give him point
in time that's my initial a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away a movie
happened that I couldn't care less about
that's a venom and the force of crushing
poverty is with him he loves everything
I hate space magic Portland
he calls himself a Jedi Knight only he
doesn't fight the dark side he picks up
garbage on the side of the road like a
prisoner here's what I know about Star
Wars a teenager doesn't want to do his
chores has daddy issues and wants to
his sister Star Wars is just a soap
opera with flashlights swords and
Muppets it's a fake religion like
Scientology the only difference is Star
Wars pays taxes and wasn't created by a
drug addict I will say it was kind of a
dick move of the franchise to kill off
Princess Leia and her mom at the same
time and why does stormtroopers bother
wearing all that armor when they always
die in one shot meanwhile the real Han
Solo's been crashing his plane in every
golf course in Southern California
but the most unrealistic part of that
movies how quickly the black guy
confessed to be in the father still if
ace wants to live every day like it's
comic-con Oh freezin in carbonite and
fly them on the Kessel run to Hollywood
in less than 12 parsecs for this week's
ce-web-rity profile yes but I've also
been known to crash on the streets from
time to time
are you still homeless no no actually
I'm renting a basement from some friends
of mine when did you convert to Jediism
in 2010 August 8th is it like Judaism
they're not really what are you doing I
got like on a day-to-day basis to make
the world a better place try and be
friendly to people behind you know you
also try to clean the city up yeah a
little bit here and there when I get to
challenge your think of adding on the
end of a lightsaber then those little
pick up things actually I had one of
those you've thought of everything
I don't know why I thought I could come
up with something that she hadn't
thought of that one profile piece that I
saw in you you were engaged and living
out of your car are you guys married now
no we we split ways decided we were much
better friends than we were partners but
did you actually get married or no no
all right so you dodged that Pollard a
good for you you're are you single right
now are you dating someone - I'm dating
someone okay let's just say you're
single soon into dating do you say by
the way I'm a Jedi day one okay can you
become a Jedi without having any
interest in Star Wars absolutely because
I am I'm not into him frankly I find the
plot to most of the Star Wars movies to
be a little drunk if George Lucas was
here right now what would you say to him
thank goodness you're not in control
anymore
is your opinion of him universal amongst
Jedi's no so I'm actually really like
the prequels I'm not one of them who's
the most famous Jedi probably the guy I
had drinks with last night in the pub
you a drinks last night with Obi McLeod
here in LA yeah he lives here
good one guys let that one slip through
the crack open the clouds right under
our goddamn noses old time you want to
hear my Yoda impression sure what
something I should say is you really
should know that sounds a lot like Miss
Piggy aren't they voiced by the same
personal friend College yeah in a head
exploded did you know that god damn is
nerds cool when did you lose your
virginity I was there came here way too
young yeah probably it's so young such a
such a force you had I'm jealous I was
so self-conscious about my my penis and
then I also remember this guy in seventh
grade that had arguably the biggest dick
I've ever seen I can remember it clear
as day just who's what good foot just
the biggest yeah it was sweet I can
never let him see my penis it's my so
small compared to his I bet it's huge
today this penis talk I'm gonna pretend
I don't have an itch in my eye I would
have given you all of my money and
converted right there if that would have
went away
Jedi's make love longer than most hard
to say I assume your selfless lover or
is that not the case no totally the case
do you always finish I'm like that in a
thousand life time of course you know
after our three sometimes it gets a
little overly sensitive all right our
three yeah you make love for three hours
okay
a penetration usually for three hours
it's so boring
I always get so cold in the theater
[Music]
I'm good - deputy - keep it in your
pants Thanks oh good one night father
[Music]
this parody is flawed I mean I enjoy
seeing characters from the original
trilogy I'm just not sure how the
storyline fits into canon c-3po was
never even programmed to use a light
[Music]
I don't need state-of-the-art graphics
to enjoy a movie a man called louvet was
the best film of the year and it cost $8
[Music]